hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the amnesia
full conversion mod when life no longer
exists now you guys have been asking me
to get back to him these are for a while
and I agreed that I would if I found a
good enough custom story and this one is
highly rated and highly suggested by you
guys so let's get to it
enter the nameless pain I didn't know
any pain had a name but let's just go
with that unearthly brutal is the maker
of this game I'm thinking that is the
name of the game chapter 1 the nameless
pain or something I'm actually really
eager to get back into it because I
haven't played amnesia in a long time
not even for myself you know
hey wait a minute can't fool me
I saw hahaha where'd that come from
something changed I could have sworn
there was a wall there wait a minute
something changed what so giant cavern
to hell opens up in the side of my wall
and everything's hunky-dory no new
candle pick up candle cool I get
something besides the lantern I think I
was a screenshot of him holding the
candle when I was on ModDB
why I have to have the same nightmare
every night the gate to hell opens in
this house everyone says that these are
just dreams
but why it always have to feel so true
ok so the grammar isn't great but I'm
gonna ignore that because I've learned
that the grammar doesn't always mean
that is it's gonna be a bad customer
story what is that is that is that a cup
oh ok
so there's custom stuff don't know
what's with the texture on that but wait
hey hey wait a minute
this is a new chair - oh cool they made
a lot of new stuff for this one I mean
it's not all like fantastic but we'll
see what we're gonna do later excuse me
sorry lots of these cups though this
door won't
open a wall all right then wait hang on
let me just check everything make sure
I'm not gonna leave anything behind
nothing nothing nothing nothing okay
let's go all right there we go I thought
I clicked that every night every single
night what is happening to me
hey wait a minute I saw that can't fool
me the quest room the questrom off on
our way oh um meteor giant monster any
of the above take your pick doesn't
really matter to me either way you're
gonna die oh no that's me I'm gonna die
all right then
all righty then starting off with a bang
are we
Oh things blowing around in the wind
Jana Rama give us something scary to do
oh hello Kate upstairs key got a key in
Hey look at that
that is cool nice work on that one oh he
couldn't have the pinky out while he was
holding that all right hey he blows it
out that's cool
nice touch man hi
is someone suffering an unimaginable
pain upstairs probably hello that is one
ugly ask carpet-ready then maybe that's
why the file size was so small because
the textures are all a little hey hi
there what are you doing
you can fly I never knew it
you're amazing do it again your yolks
playing okay no useless dabei was it so
is that a bull's horn really ornate
bull's horn hear there's an axe in the
table hmm not a good sign oh hello I can
use the axe yeah let me ask you a
question there buddy
it's nightmare house 2 all over again
yeah all right yeah can I get the giant
Claymore sore I can't
oh oh you monsters don't even know what
you're about to get well I can tell you
it's a giant sword through the chest but
other than is that a monster who wants
to test my mettle better than growling
I'm ready for you you monster bastards
ha ha done done done
all right let's get this started I got a
key but I haven't been able to find
anything else I guess that's all I
needed
hello that door looks weird
if you got custom noise - well done
boiler room I don't need to go there who
are you to tell me what I need to do
you're me but just the voice in my head
I know what I need to do I need to go
through the exit apparently is this the
exit key it doesn't work like that well
then how does it work really it doesn't
work maybe this one this one was the
only a lock door in here there we go all
right what this isn't upstairs what you
talking about what you talking about
what you talking about - I just had to
do that oh there we go upstairs oh whoa
I heard somebody growling maybe it was
the wind maybe it was something else oh
no dude this is your house but your
house is really weird man you think
you're doing is that a candle new candle
vibe
is there anything under the stairs hello
what of that what is that is that a
candle what is that must be a new
texture never seen it before but man
this guy put a lot of effort in is that
a new chair - looks like a new one well
done baron the other one you made was
that an explosion and who puts a dining
area under that stairs I made at least
something's under the stairs but come on
that's not very practical Oh what is
this are you some sick statue collecting
freak
hi hi hi Billy
Billy it's me something weirds going on
in this house can you help me out balle
balle you okay y'all look so good
Billy all right I'll meet up with you
later Billy all right okay
thanks ed there were new monsters in
this game by the way so I'm looking
forward to hi excuse me I was trying to
read that okay nope not in a million
years I'm going in that room not ever in
a million years you can't make me
I could instantly tell my note meters
went off the chart for that room no
thank you
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope no way no way in hell
you go to hell and you die I'll be come
on you guys agree with me that was that
was a 100% nope room oh I got to go in
and don't I I was just yeah nope okay
we're gonna carry on without that it was
that what is what's the statues man
it's really weird you're it's really
weird man I'm trying to read these books
you're just breaking everything right in
front of my face what's the deal what's
the deal buddy what's steel friend
friend oh I'm a friendly buddy man at
least my roommate Billy cleans up after
himself but I'm just making a mess this
with my sanity am I already going dead
why why what happened
yeah whatever okay no all right not
going that way either hey Billy Billy
where'd you go where'd you go Billy oh
we must have went off to his room
hi hey there you are you studying
where'd you go well hey what do I let's
go find him
I really like all the new stuff that's
in this custom story there's a lot of
just really creative stuff going on
Billy he's always practicing his music
man that guy he's got to be a great
musician someday but oh wait he wasn't
playing what's going on
it's so weird door won't open
oh man I'm gonna have to go down that
hallway or night ow
why door won't open
right terrif ha ha ha oh this has bad
news written all over it
it's dark down there oh no I don't think
any house looks like this what do you
realize that you are in damnation you
will begin to seek forgiveness what the
hell was that I don't even know and I do
not want to know you think whatever that
was what happened here
Oh My lordy Lou what is going on what
the hell well you could have just stuck
some rocks in there you didn't have to
throw the entire house up there what's
going on whoa la la
Oh My lordy hello Alexander what are you
doing here yeah it's so wrong
it's so wrong that a dead body Billy are
you okay Billy hi
stop hi where's your face oh okay well
that's perfectly fine then the roof
isn't in good condition
it needs repairing it fast I'm glad
you're thinking about these things when
eternal damnation rains upon you where
am I now
oh I'm in this room is that daylight or
something oh man it almost looks good
yeah so cheerful already then well down
here the old dusty trail and get the
water hell ha ha ha the whole place is
collapsing alrighty then
oh this light is on do I get another key
second double extra bonus key but
goblets no key alright looks like we got
to go to the quest room for some reason
questrom these nightmares are making me
crazy but the bogeyman might be real
boogeyman I know I don't want to know
more about it well too late you're
already in the thick of it and this is
looking to be look
hello that must be the boiler I guess hi
enjoy that chair hat you like it you
look so good mmm that looks so good upon
you hmm all right I wonder what other
diabolical destiny of damnation and
derelict did to deliver the crema tude
awaits me I'm not good at alliteration I
another key double extra bonus key
doesn't seem like anything has any sort
of glow around it which is what I'm used
to and I almost missed that key even in
broad daylight key is that really
necessary
yeah how long have you been in this
house bro there are 10 there is 10
levers and 3 gates in this room each one
of the 3 levers opens a gate and rest of
them drops all the gate down too
carefully it's kind of a memory game
okay test one it do not think test two
it do not think has to test test oh this
is gonna suck what is going on there
what's going on here nope nope nope nope
whoa what if maybe I got to pull them
down up up up up up up up got one
okay so that one brings the middle one
up that one brings the back one up oh
whoa
wait which one was that there we go
there we go and there we go I am too
proud for this memory game my left foot
all right
anyway we need to go in the machine room
but we're all out of time for now so
sick time remember okay stick around for
the next episode let me know what you
think of this custom story and the thing
the delink afford to play for yourself
is in the description below so thank you
all so much for watching click the ends
days before videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
but my wicked baby just inspected told
me to run away
good size
[Music]
what
well